Alicia is with us in Buffalo New York I
Alicia welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay my fiancee NRA
together we have a total of three
hundred dollars in student loans three
hundred thousand dollars in student loan
debt and then like sixty thousand
additional debt when are you getting
married well that's the thing I
personally have been trying to postpone
it because I'm just exercise even
thinking about a wedding and we have so
much debt to deal with okay let's break
it up let's break it up then because we
don't have debt until we are married so
how much student loan debt do you have I
have about two hundred and sixty dollars
worth of student debt currently and I
have two more years of my my doctoral
program what are you studying pray tell
I know I'm getting my background in
nursing your bachelor oh you mean your
beer you're getting a PhD in nursing
it's a it's a it's a doctorate program
so it's different it's like more
clinical than a PhD so it's really a
nurse practitioner program but just for
the doctoral level why because I wanted
to further my career I wanted to make
more money and have to work less hours
yes sir you could get a lot quicker and
you would be in exactly the same setting
right again as a nurse practitioner you
could get that a lot quicker and you'd
be in exactly the same position with
your career wouldn't you yeah but how
does a doctoral above nurse practitioner
further your career um it just gives me
you know different options and they're
they're currently working on trying to
move all of the nurse practitioner to
that tour
status at a certain point so you know
but they're not all right that's not
happening right now
okay so close in my area they that's
pretty much what all they're they're
starting to offer is the factorial
they're getting rid of a lot of the
master's programs for that reason so
anyways yeah so and I mean I'm so deep
in it that it's either way so it's not
wasted you've already got enough to be
on our end don't you well yeah I mean I
was the van our answer for quite a while
before I started this program oh I see
and that was the two hundred and sixty
thousand dollars in debt for a long time
so I you know put myself through I got
the associates and then I got a
bachelor's and two hundred sixty
thousand dollars in debt to be an RN
what I wanted to do when I was young it
figured out that I wanted to do this
okay you know no I will not get a
doctoral while you're two hundred sixty
thousand dollars in debt as an RN you
can work a hundred hours a week if you
want to and you can make bank and clean
up your dadgum mess you have a huge
student loan debt and you're just piling
on more I mean you have a mess kiddo
and you're not doing anything except
making a bigger mess because the
difference in your income after you
finish this doctoral program and what it
is today isn't squat right so you're
just collecting degrees at this point
where like it's not like I can stop and
come back to it later yeah but you said
you had two years more to go
yeah so you're going to be four hundred
and something thousand dollars and that
is that what you're telling me it would
probably be an additional 25,000
twenty-five thousand in two years so
you're going to be 300 thousand or so in
debt and you're gonna have a doctoral in
nursing
are you working while you're doing this
well it's not really a program that you
can you know it's a per diem but I work
you know varying hours so I mean I bring
home after taxes probably about four
thousand a month from that you know to
try to compensate um but I feel like
it's honest if you're out [ __ ] I mean
I'm kind of in a place where I have to
finish I don't I can't transfer
somewhere later on it'll be like nothing
graduate school is only transfer like
six credits at most I'm halfway through
the program so there's a bachelor's to
doctorate work a thousand hours and pay
cash from this point forward but don't
go further in debt this is the you
you've been on a suicide trip here I
mean this is you this is a mess and it's
not your fiance's it's yours
what does he make so he makes about me
he makes fifty and I make between 45 and
50 sometimes what does he do for a
living you know I mean he has plans too
how long have you been engaged well I
think you guys have gotta decide what
you're gonna do and I can't decide that
for you this is your life you're gonna
have to make your calls if you are going
to get married I would just go ahead and
do it if he's willing to take this on
and the two of you are willing to work
your way through this debt together but
I don't think you can sit around and say
I have to clean this up before we get
married you're not gonna get married for
a decade if you do that
and so I think if you're gonna get
married you should go ahead and get
married and the two of you take your
$100,000 income don't go further in debt
and then begin to attack the debt and
claw your way out from there and that's
what I would do so hey thanks for the
call
appreciate you joining us